for more information on tutoring or how
to support move university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university comm thank you and enjoy
so in this video we'll discuss atomic
spectra and specifically the hydrogen
spectrum and the Rydberg equation so
here we have a Sun and the Sun gives off
light
we've got sunlight if we take that
sunlight and pass it through a thin slit
like we've got here specifically this
portion so the hole we can take that the
sunlight pass it through a slit and then
following that we'll pass it through a
prism grab a glass prism that will
refract or bend the light and what we'll
see is a spectrum let's look the rainbow
right maybe some of you have actually
done this before
shine light through a prism and saw that
you would project a rainbow like this
now this is a spectrum of colors of
course going from violet to red and the
colors are changing continuously so this
is a continuous spectrum one color kind
of blends into the next one and we
progress from violet to indigo to blue
green yellow orange and right okay this
isn't the best depiction out there for a
spectrum I'd encourage you to look up a
better image than this but you can see
how the colors can continually change
from one of the next okay now atoms they
can be excited by heat thermally or by
electricity electrically to give off
light as well and that light can be
passed through a slit and refracted as
well however the result is that it's not
refracted in quite the same way so here
we have a tube of hydrogen gas this is
hydrogen gas here and light it's excited
okay and when it is excited it gives off
light that we're passing through a slit
just like we did before followed by a
prism and then that light is refracted
and we get a spectrum here as well but
not quite the same
so here instead of seeing continuous
color changes we see thin lines each of
different colors with darkness in
between them this is a line spectrum
okay so we see thin lines that are sort
of shaped like the slit is and these
lines are of different colors that have
corresponding wavelengths and in between
them is just darkness now this is
specifically hydrogen's line spectrum so
here we have hydrogen's line spectrum
we've got the wavelength in nanometers
going from 400 to 750 here so we've got
violet has it's at about 4 10.1
nanometers the blue line is at 434 0.1
the green line is at 486 point one and
the orange line over here is at 656
point 3 okay now notice that I only put
the visible portion of the spectrum here
there are other parts of it that are
just not shown for simplicity's sake so
the question is what does this mean
about this hydrogen line spectrum what's
what's the point of this well what this
means is that the hydrogen atom emits
only certain values or certain quanta of
energy right that correspond to these
different wavelengths of the colors so
when we're talking about Tomic line
spectra an equation that's often
associated with it is the Rydberg
equation the Rydberg equation and the
Rydberg equation is this 1 over lambda
equals R parenthesis 1 over m squared
minus 1 over N squared close parentheses
so what is this thing
well lambda refers to wavelength in
meters which we've seen before and R is
new or is a constant specifically the
Rydberg constant and it's equal to one
point zero nine six seven seven six
times ten to the seventh one over meters
right so the units of here are
basically the reciprocal of the units
here m and n are integers that are
unitless such that n is greater than M
and I do not have a unit what's the
purpose of this Rydberg equation it's
used to predict the wavelength of any
line or lines in a series okay now if M
equals one that corresponds to the
ultraviolet series of the UV series if M
equals two that corresponds to the
visible series M equals three talk about
the infrared or IR series so this part
might not make a lot of sense quite yet
it'll make hopefully a little bit more
sense in the next video on the Bohr
model okay now let's do some practice
problems that relate to the Rydberg
equation so here we got a question with
two parts a and B so a says given that M
equals 1 what is the longest possible
wavelength in the spectrum so they tell
us that m equals 1 and they want us to
find the wavelength so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to basically solve the
Rydberg equation for wavelength and go
from there so if the Rydberg equation is
this I'm going to solve for wavelength
by writing first writing the equation as
it's given so 1 over wavelength equals R
times 1 over M squared minus 1 over N
squared so basically if I just if I
cross multiply here if I just put this
come and erase this a little bit if I
just put this over 1 and I cross
multiply I get if I just cross multiply
here here I get 1 equals lambda R times
1 over M squared minus 1 over N squared
and then I could just divide both sides
by this whole thing except the lambda
so that our 1 minus or 1 over m squared
minus 1 over N squared
- that's both sides 1 over m squared
minus 1 over N squared and then here
this cancels ok and I'm just left with
lambda equals 1 over that whole thing
with the are 1 over m squared minus 1
over N squared
okay so I've solved it for wavelength
I've done this because they're asking me
what is the longest possible wavelength
so they want me to find the wavelength
now they tell me that M equals 1
ok so M equals 1 and I also know that
the R the R is the constant right so I'm
going to plug that in so we'll have 1
over we round to a few sig figs here for
the constant I'll just have one point
zero nine seven times 10 to the seventh
one over meters and one over one squared
it's just one but I have 1 minus o minus
1 over N squared okay so what's going on
here now I don't know what n is they
didn't tell me what n is so but they did
tell me what is the they ask me what is
the longest possible wavelength in the
spectrum and I think that's best showing
purely by just giving you the example
here and showing you just telling you
first of all that n will be longer
assuming the wavelength will be longest
when n is as small as possible
but remember that n has to be greater
than M so the smallest value that I can
put here is two okay so that's what I'll
do plug in a 2 here so I'll put let's
just make this quicker and easier
because I have technology here I'll
replace that end with a 2 so I have 1
minus 1 over 2 squared which is 4 so
I'll have 1 over this constant one point
zero nine seven times 10 to the seventh
one over meters and then this is going
to basically be 1 minus 1 minus 1/4
right which is just 3/4 so I'm gonna
write that here 3/4 and if I plug this
into my calculator I will get one point
two one five times 10 to the negative 7
meters which also equals 120 one point
five nanometers so that is the largest
possible wavelength given that M equals
one that is as large as possible
wavelength just to show you let me plug
in 3 if you plug I'm not going to show
all the work for it I'll just write here
that if if you plug in N equals 3 what
you get is that the wavelength will you
basically have 1 minus 1 over 3 squared
which is 1 minus 1 over 9 right which
gives you 8 ninths here so the
wavelength in that case will be one
point zero 2 6 times 10 to the negative
seventh meters which is approximately if
we put that in nanometers 1/100 2.6
nanometers so notice here that if N
equals 3 we have
a wavelength that's a little bit smaller
but it's the next biggest right so you
can imagine that as you plug in numbers
for n that are bigger and bigger and
bigger the wavelength that you end up
getting is going to be smaller and
smaller and smaller
okay so then they ask you what would be
the shortest possible wavelength so all
this work was for a right part a let's
do Part B what is the shortest possible
wavelength well we're still going to use
the this equation here solved for
wavelength right wavelength equals this
right that's the equation we're going to
be using so 1 over R times 1 over 1
squared or actually I'll just plug this
all in here because we know what R is
already one point zero nine seven times
ten to the seventh one over meters and
we know that M equals one so we'll have
1 over one squared minus one over and
now the question is now what to put in
for n well we want the shortest possible
wavelength well in the case of the
previous example we had the longest
possible wavelength it just we had to
make n as small as possible just keeping
in mind that n had to be bigger than M
so we just picked the smallest integer
that's bigger than 1 which was 2 but now
we want the shortest possible
wavelengths we want n to be as big as
possible so I'll write that here so n as
big as possible for Part B ok so but I
can go on for integers forever right so
what can I put in here well if I can go
on forever what does that really mean
that means infinity right so if I put in
infinity here what that basically makes
makes happen is that 1 divided by a
really really really large number is
effectively 0 right so I have 1 over 1
squared minus 0 which is just 1 right so
then I'll have 1 over 1 point zero nine
seven times 10 to the seventh one over
meters times 1 over 1 squared minus 0
which is 1 minus 0 which is just 1 and
if I plug that in I will get
nine point one one six times ten to the
negative eighth meters which is in
nanometers ninety one point one six
nanometers so that would be the shortest
possible wavelength when n is as big as
possible which is infinity so notice
that of course this this value is
smaller than this value this is the
biggest this is the longest possible
wavelength and this is the shortest
possible wavelength assuming that M
equals one hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying